when GOP puts forth a wait no no no no
no no no no no you can't I'm answering
okay these people lie about everything
and of course if I'm talking about liars
we must show you a clip of cringe
Jean-Pierre uh answering or actually not
answering a question from Fox news's
Peter Ducey
1000 people
illegally cry border and in his little
deck so what do you call it Peter when
GOP puts forth wait no no no no no no no
no no you can't I'm answering okay
no no we're moving
Peter I tried to answer the question you
stopped me let's go she's she's just
terrible at her job put aside anything
else you think of her she's just
terrible at her job it is a completely
legitimate question what do you guys
call it what do you call it when we see
all these people invading the country
and then she starts going on about the
GOP the GOP is not in charge of the
border the president is in charge of the
Border it's on that very short list of
what that brain adult fool is supposed
to do and he's not I can't even say he's
not doing it they are intentionally
doing this but she tries to turn into
the GOP and he's like no no no no I'm
not gonna have it and then she just
moves on because she has no answer and I
would just like to say for the record
and for you freaks over at Media Matters
who are watching the show right now my
criticism of her has nothing to do with
the fact that she's black or a chick or
a lesbo those are all great things those
are spectacular wonderful things and she
should be credited accordingly my
criticism of her is because she is a
horrible White House spokesperson or a
Administration that is a complete
embarrassment